hi I'm Dolph Lundgren check out my new
movie Universal Soldier dear record not
available
you'll see jean-claude van damme Scott
add me as Universal soldiers Commission
Universal Soldier day of reckoning
watch it now on iTunes before it's in
theaters November 30th what we're
dealing with with the Universal Soldier
is it's the modern retelling of
Frankenstein it's about humans playing
God and creating these characters and of
course inevitably they end up coming up
to the guys that created them soldier
once again I'm playing Andrew Scott I
started playing this character you know
what twenty years ago and the first
universe of silver in 1991 the violence
is very realistic and grindin on the
limit of being too much but I think it
works for the subject matter does work
the whole story is essentially kind of a
journey into the heart of darkness of
this character of John to discover who
he is
have you ever seen this man his name is
Luke Devereaux his prints were all over
the crime scene it doesn't exactly know
who he is but he knows that this man
killed his family and he's going to find
him and destroy him if you go looking
for Devereaux he'll find you first
JCVD is jean-claude as I call him his
character was a bit Brad to ask a bit of
Apocalypse Now and I thought you know
kind of fitted right into the storyline
she believed I did
then they did and my character as he
goes through the movie he starts off
just running away trying to survive is
he's not a fighter doesn't realize that
he's got certain powers and then as the
film progresses he evolves into a
killing machine
the car chase with me and Andre offski
the leads into the fire sequence India
the warehouse store that's my favorite
scene in the film it's pretty relentless
we were using real baseball bats points
it was pretty crazy he's coming at me
with the realize because it looks better
when real things hit objects and they
smash apart I love working with the
stunt guys and occasionally you get one
that's willing to take a full-on kick to
the head and we love guys like that
because it just looks so great in slow
motion it's very cinematic thing to kick
somebody in the face full force so there
was this one particular stuntman he just
said yeah go on I just just kick me in
the head
ended up doing three tapes of it and the
guy said listen let's just get this down
so I just kicked some full force in
there but then it looks beautiful
but you can go in there and just for an
action film and be extremely entertained
and fulfilled but if you want a bit more
from the story then you're certainly
gonna be able to get that as well I'd
say there was a lot of violence
it took me about two weeks to get rid of
all the blood for my my body we decided
that this genre this movie is really
sci-fi and war it has action in it but
it's a sci-fi noir in the same way that
you know Blade Runner is sci-fi doir
jean-claude van Damme
spotted kick
and Dolph Lundgren
Universal Soldier day of reckoning watch
it now on iTunes before it's in theaters
November 30th